[Music]
hello everyone thank you very much for
coming this is my first time speaking at
a movie theater I think your seats are
fully automated so recline get
comfortable I'd also like to welcome
everyone who's listening online I'm here
to help you transform your business with
cloud GPUs so this talk is about
supercomputers from machine learning
these multiple generations of custom
Asics boards systems and whole
supercomputers that we've designed here
at Google and are making available
through the cloud I've got lots of
interesting things to say about our
recent product announcements some new
performance and cost information and
more but before we get to that I just
want to set the context here for those
of you who are new to the field are new
to hardware acceleration especially in
the cloud so people have been calling
the end of Moore's law for decades now
so I'm a little nervous about this but I
think it's finally over sequential
processing is finally plateauing so you
can't just wait for new processors to
come along and take your sequential
program and make it magically run faster
and we're reaching this plateau after
this amazing wild ride just at the
moment that businesses have to manage
more data than ever before now you're
all familiar with these different kinds
of data in the images and video category
you might have billions of images of
user-generated content or live video
streams for video calls and short videos
that people are sharing with each other
or sharing to show products or real
estate or other spaces
you've got product imagery for retail
and e-commerce you'll hear a little bit
more about that later do you a spatial
imagery in ever higher resolution
medical imagery navigational imagery for
autonomous vehicles robotics
manufacturing for quality control and
more in the text speech and audio domain
there are messaging systems with people
sending uncountably many messages every
day product reviews forum comments that
you need to moderate and rank and route
new voice interfaces that are taking the
world by storm support requests that can
come in many modalities whether
in-person
text
voice calls even video you get lots of
call center audio accumulating and you
want to get business insights out of it
and then music recommendation is just a
an entire world onto itself and these
are just a sample of the types of data
that's accumulating across all of your
businesses that could be very valuable
for you to process with this cutting
edge of machine learning and these
cutting edge supercomputers so the good
news is there's been tremendous progress
working with unstructured data
especially over the past few years as
you can see here looking at image
recognition in this case on the image
net standard benchmark there have been
dramatic increases in the top one
accuracy in just five years and the
accuracy continues to increase
especially if some of these new
techniques like learning to learn or
Otto amel and it's not just image
recognition this is not just about image
net these new deep neural networks and a
sort of broader class of computationally
intensive new machine learning
algorithms provide a unified approach
across many different application
domains ranging from imagery to speech
to text to scenes and this is a huge
change from when I was in grad school
during my PhD in computer vision the
techniques weren't very similar between
say computer vision and natural language
processing whereas now you can use a
single computational framework whether
that's tensorflow or another framework
of your choice to express many different
model architectures that all are built
under the same building blocks and those
are the kinds of building blocks that we
can now accelerate with this new custom
hardware so how do we manage these
profound increases in compute
requirements for the most valuable new
machine learning applications well as
you can see here going back to the image
recognition challenge on imagenet the
vertical axis here is accuracy of these
models sort of a selection of
interesting models over the past few
years and then the horizontal axis is
computational cost and as you can see to
get to those highest levels of accuracy
you tend to need more and more
computation processing each image and
also to train these models even on this
data set of a fixed size with image net
and so in some applications you can get
away with a lower accuracy and that's
fine but in other applications when you
think about autonomous driving or
medical imaging or others every
additional percentage point of accuracy
is literally saving lives
and so there's there's real urgency to
get at this space that's currently
bounded by the computation we can afford
to apply so openly I recently published
a blog post called AI and compute where
they did an analysis similar to this one
but now it's on a log scale you can see
the vertical axis is computation cost on
a log scale and then here they've
plotted this over time and highlighted
several models that are especially well
known that have provided new
capabilities over the past few years
starting with Aleks net which kicked off
this most recent wave of excitement
about machine learning and then you see
even better image classification models
as I showed on the previous slide
require even more compute but again it's
not just restricted to image recognition
we have speech recognition models like
deep speech to in here we have machine
translation models requiring even more
compute to deliver these amazing
breakthrough results in neural machine
translation we have real-time game
playing that opening eye is working on
and there will be more this August there
and then also world champion go playing
programs up here demanding tremendous
amounts of compute for the self play to
learn the game and learn the strategies
all on its own so if you step back and
look at this picture what you really see
is that to get at these valuable new
capabilities you need to throw as much
compute as you can at the problem and
that's what's been driving all this
progress over time so opening I called
out a couple of important insights that
I'd like to highlight here and I won't
read all these out I recommend that you
look at the blog post in its entirety
but I'd say that first of all the simple
rule seems to hold across a wide variety
of domains that more compute seems to
lead predictably to better performance
as they say here in the in the blog post
and it's complementary to algorithmic
advances so it's great to try new
algorithms and new ideas and as I'll say
later there's still lots of progress to
be made that way but that's
complementary to also
having an enormous amount of compute to
drive accuracy as far as you can go with
the best ideas that you've uncovered and
now in the law right here this is the
most interesting insight that the number
two track is not the speed of your
single accelerator or the capacity of
your biggest data center but it's
something in between it's the amount of
compute that you can productively apply
to train a single model this is what the
folks at opening I believe is most
likely to correlate to how powerful the
very best models in the field are and
it's really this that's driving us not
just to build new chips or new single
machine systems but these connected
supercomputers that we call TPU pods
because those are enabling us to apply
the largest possible amount of compute
to train a single model that can also be
subdivided to to Train many models at
once so how does this overview relate to
your business well there are two
perspectives that I think you might find
valuable you can come at this from the
point of view of the people that you
have in your organization or that you're
hoping to hire or acquire and bring in
their companies you can also think about
this from the perspective of data and
I'll go through these in turn so first
of all people if you look around in your
organization and you have people who
call themselves machine learning
engineers or machine learning
researchers it's obvious that they need
an enormous amount of compute they're
typically just budget limited no matter
how much compute you have with all these
models that are so compute hungry and
these enormous data sets they'll rapidly
find a way to use the compute that they
have available and they'll ask you for
more you're probably already hearing
them ask for as much compute as they can
get also data scientists though we and
other teams across the industry are
working hard to make it easier and
easier to apply these techniques so even
if you're not ready to write a model in
raw tensorflow that's okay because there
are more and more open source reference
models available that deliver high
performance and can easily be adapted
and can fit into sort of a more standard
data science workflow too even for folks
who don't have a PhD in machine learning
that's not required furthermore over in
product development it's an open
question how to take all these new
capabilities that are just newly being
suppose with machine learning and use
them to unlock new kinds of experiences
and services I think we're just in the
early stages of that at Google i/o this
year we showed a demo of Google duplex
which is a new way of interacting with
businesses through the assistant that's
just one example of what I believe is
going to be a whole forest of new
opportunities for new products to take
these capabilities and integrate them in
a natural way into our lives once you
have those products and they're out in
production your compute needs to scale
with your number of users if you have
something that's hosted server siding
you have a billion users you've got to
handle billions of requests coming in
simultaneously and that requires a lot
of compute and in between research to
production and you know even once a
model is live it's really important to
do continuous integration and testing
machine learning models look a lot
different from the software that you're
probably used to testing it's subtle
changes in your input data or any layer
of your compute stack all the way down
can lead to changes in accuracy of your
model and so it's important and what we
do at Google is we're retraining these
models all the time on every new version
of our software and testing for
regressions and passing as much of that
as we can along to you through our open
source reference models and I'll say
more about that later but you'll need to
do this too for the products that you
develop and and launch and I listed
enthusiastic interns here because I
think it's important not just to make
the compute available to the people with
the most seniority or the the most
obvious titles in your organization like
the ones that I've listed before this
whole field is moving so fast there are
so many students being trained both
formally and informally that it's
possible that someone who's just joined
your company as an intern who's
sufficiently motivated could deliver an
enormous breakthrough if they have
access to this level of compute and can
work with the data that you have and
talk to your product teams so I think
it's really important to make this new
large scale compute widely available
both inside your organizations and
outside and that's what we're trying to
help all of you do so in the past the
key determinant of progress was
typically waiting for your code to
compile
right there's that famous xkcd cartoon
about this now in this new world of
working with enormous datasets and
training these gigantic accurate ML
models and then serving them the key
determinant of progress of your team is
how long it takes for them to wait for
the machine learning models to train and
for production models this can currently
take weeks or even months and so imagine
if your code took months to compile it's
really important to pull that in two
hours minutes even seconds to make your
team's more productive let them try them
multiple things at once get results and
iterate instead of just waiting for days
or weeks or longer so now looking at
this from the data perspective now the
kinds of ideal data sets that I
described earlier for cutting-edge ml
typically have hundreds of thousands of
data points millions of data points or
even billions of data points in them and
in most but not all of these
cutting-edge domains it's important to
have high quality labels or at least the
ability to create them so typically with
user-generated content photos videos you
might have tags that your users are
already applying in other cases when
you're collecting geospatial imagery you
can build a team to label it or do some
sort of augmented approach to labeling
it and there many labeling services
coming online now but there are also all
these sensors going out whether it's in
mobile phones or autonomous vehicles or
new kinds of robots or factories or
elsewhere and those are all streaming
data in that can be valuable for
cutting-edge machine learning
simulations too can be a valuable way to
generate data whether game environments
or robotic simulations or other types of
simulators and I'm call it here
explicitly at the bottom bottom agents
and robots interacting with an
environment you're currently seeing this
mostly on the research side now but I
think it won't be long before you start
seeing this in real production systems
but these are just starting points for
you to look around your business at all
the data that you have or could easily
collect and look for data that's related
to the prediction problems that matter
right and once you find a large data set
there that's a good starting point for
figuring out how to take this technology
and have an immediate impact on your
business
so suppose
have the people you have the data what
do you do next well I recommend that you
access the fastest hardware that you can
and ideally in the cloud and you might
say well what's the advantage of going
to the cloud I could just buy some
accelerators and plug them in here we
already have a data center that's where
our data is why should I change well
the advantages especially of Google
cloud over on Prem hosting of your own
accelerators are that you get a lot of
flexibility when you're planning for
your own data center they're these
enormous lead times the capital expenses
it's very complicated to set things up
and these new accelerators are power
dense their networking dense they change
a lot of things about the way that you
need to plan your data center we
announced at Google i/o that our version
3 GPUs are actually liquid cooled so you
know if you think that that's a signal
of where the field is going do you want
to bring liquid cooling at your data
center it's complicated whereas in the
cloud you can just mix and match and
software the components that you need
you can provision quickly and scale up
as your needs change or scale back down
if a burst of traffic has passed and now
that you're in a short law there's
built-in security I think one theme that
you've heard throughout this conference
is that Google cloud is the leader in
security and we have powerful tools for
data access user control and more
encourage you to consult the other
sessions just to see how deep Google's
commitment is to security in the cloud
and as I mentioned at the beginning
reducing capital expenses is really
fantastic on demand pricing and
preemptable pricing lets you pay only
for what you need and scale up and down
so now let's talk about these TP use and
these TPS are only in Google cloud our
version one is actually not in the cloud
this was in our data center since 2015
it was our first foray into the space
when Jeff Dean worried that if every
Android user talked to their phones for
just three minutes a day the speech
recognition algorithm that we were
running at the time would have required
us to double our number of data centers
so that wasn't going to work and so
there was this crash project to develop
an accelerator that you now interact
with every time you run a search or you
use google photos or a street view or a
bunch of Google's other services are
running either on this or it's
successors now here is the cloud TPU
this is an example of
Google's second-generation teepee use in
a system that's widely available today
no signup required no waiting this is
now generally available it's in the
United States it's in Europe it's in
Asia and you can find out more by going
to G KO / cloud GPU the nice thing about
these teepee use is that they weren't
just single machine systems though like
I mentioned before they're designed to
be connected together into these
enormous supercomputers that we call TPU
pods and the exciting thing here that's
been mentioned obliquely but I want to
make very clear is that our cloud TPU
pod with these v2 TPU is now available
in alpha and you'll hear a little bit
more later about how people have already
been using it to accelerate their
businesses furthermore as you may have
heard in the keynotes v3 is also in
alpha and so if you're interested in
trying out the next generation of
performance contact cloud sales or cloud
support and get access to these amazing
machines also we revealed that these v3
TPU is just like the v2 are designed to
be connected together into even larger
liquid-cooled supercomputers that we
revealed at Google i/o so what I'm
trying to show you here is that we're
deeply committed to making relentless
progress in performance in cost in scale
of these kinds of accelerators for both
inference and training and to pass those
benefits along to you and in businesses
in universities as individuals in
startups all around the world so as you
can see here we've gone from 92 tera ops
and inference only to 180 teraflops for
training and inference with the club TPU
v2 and then with v3 we're now going with
a single device that you see pictured
here up to 420 teraflops
we've also doubled the memory and this
is really important if batch sizes have
been a limitation for you or you want to
go to larger models that are difficult
to fit on a single device that you have
today
now suddenly your device has 420
teraflops and 128 gigabytes of RAM
extremely high bandwidth ram actually so
that's an alpha check it out
looking at the pods the pod that's
available today
eleven-and-a-half petaflop s-- four
terabytes of ram and this mesh network
that makes for really efficient
communication without any code changes
on your part and then the TPU v3 pod
that we announced at i/o goes above a
hundred petaflop s-- with 32 terabytes
of ram so this is not just sticking a
lot more of the same machine together
it's a whole new chip architecture in
addition to this larger scale system
that really delivers these results
furthermore I want to call out that as
of yesterday here at cloud next cloud
GPU pricing has gotten even better we've
got promotional pricing that we've
introduced across all of our regions
that take the price for renting a cloud
TPU
in u.s. central for example down to four
dollars and fifty cents an hour and the
amazing thing is if you can tolerate
checkpointing and occasionally having to
recover your work if it gets interrupted
which is an easy thing to do in machine
learning you can use preemptable TP use
for just a dollar thirty five an hour
this is an unprecedented step to make
machine learning more affordable for
everyone and so we hope that this helps
you both get started with our new
platform comfortably and for those of
you in these large organizations to
scale up way beyond anything you're able
to contemplate now so what's the user
experience for these club GPUs well
today the best way to program these
cloud TV users with tensorflow and in
particular tensorflow is a is a wide and
vast open source framework for machine
learning it's the most popular in the
world on github it's one of the top five
projects and github overall and
programming tip used to get the highest
performance you'll typically use a
subset of the tensorflow api's TF data
to manage your input processing layers
estimators and then you go through the
excel a compiler over there in the lower
right to give you a sense of what this
looks like
and by the way these these api's are not
specific to CPUs if you implement your
models this way our intention over time
is for it to require less and less
change for you to just flip a
configuration flag and run your code on
GPU or on CPU so we're really trying to
get to the point where you can write
your machine learning models once and
then transparently
advantage of whatever hardware you have
available and deploy on whatever
hardware you want out at the edge
whether that's in a phone or in a
vehicle or you know in some other edge
application so focusing on layers and
estimators for a second though here's
some sample code of a typical computer
vision model unmodified for TPU and then
here's an example of the types of
modifications you have to make today and
again we're trying to reduce these over
time just a couple lines have changed
here around the optimizer and the
estimator and so I want to emphasize
though that you're not just limited to
tensorflow
programming tepees a lot of people think
oh well what if I use some other
framework or what if I want flexibility
to try multiple ways of interacting with
these accelerators that's just fine and
in fact as of ten to one point 10 we
announced here at cloud next that we
have initial chaos integration with
cloud GPUs and this gives you even more
flexibility and convenience and it gives
you an incremental path for taking the
chaos code that you have today running
it on the TPU and then gradually
optimizing the performance maybe of the
input pipeline or other parts of it to
get to unlock more and more of the
performance that these cloud GPUs can
deliver so if you're choosing between
one or the other the way to think about
this is on the Left TPU estimator gives
you a peak performance right it scales
two pods with zero code changes which is
truly amazing if you've ever tried to
write a distributed system this is a
fantastic convenience it's got some
Erinn robustness you can easily export
models for inference on CPUs GPUs or
GPUs and then Kaos has sort of a
complementary advantage with easy
development non-static shapes numpy
input and then experimental TS data
integration so definitely recommend
trying them both and seeing which one
better suits your use case cloud GPUs
are integrated tightly with tensor board
which lets you track what your model is
doing and we have this fantastic
profiler tab that lets you take captured
TPU profiles and examine them in
enormous detail people have given us
tremendous feedback positive feedback on
how valuable this is to understand what
their models are
doing on this new hardware this is this
is something that people really love
that are using GPUs today for example we
even have a frame here that calls out in
red I don't know if you can read it but
it's telling you that your program is
not input bounded so this is a great
time to optimize the mapping of your
model onto the hardware whereas in other
cases it might say your input bounded
don't worry about the model optimize
your input pipeline because you're not
able to feed data fast enough to keep up
with these accelerators I'd also like to
emphasize that cloud GPUs are different
in another way that gives you more
flexibility there network-attached
rather than being directly attached to
your virtual machines and what that
means is you the customer here on the
left this particular customers here in
the room is connected to an arbitrary
compute engine VM in the center there
that can be whatever you want large
small and it can actually be very small
because all the heavy compute is
happening behind the scenes on the cloud
TPU so that can be an n1 standard 2 you
don't need a big VM to drive and then
communicating over network with this
cloud GPU ordinary open-source
tensorflow is able to drive your
computation you know reading and data
from GCS or elsewhere now we've got
cloud BigTable integrations and G RPC
integrations and other ways of getting
data into these devices but also that
cloud CPU doesn't have to just be a
single device it can be a whole slice of
a pod and so this extra network step
means you don't have to fight with
drivers anymore you just use these
machine images that we provide and you
can scale up and down easily from an
infrastructure point of view as well as
from a code point of view so let me say
a little bit more about scaling up on
these pods so from a samples per second
point of view these pods are designed to
scale and so you see perfect linear
scaling behavior in terms of in this
case with resident a while back how many
images were processed per second as we
scale up the number of devices connected
with our special superfast network I
just want to emphasize again this means
distributed training of machine learning
models can finally be easy there are
fantastic contributions outside it's a
tensor flow there's hoar Avadh there's
other things which if you have a bespoke
cluster with InfiniBand that can really
scale
all the expertise to operate it you can
achieve fantastic results but this is I
think the easiest way to achieve this
level of scale in any public cloud today
furthermore you might wonder well but if
I make the batch size that large is my
model still going to converge and the
answer is it depends but the research is
looking very promising there's very
active research on this right now and
what you're seeing here is on the time
axis that orange dot is a single device
training a model to a certain accuracy
and then you can see here as we've tuned
the hyper parameters and gone to a
larger and larger slice of the pod you
can still hit that same accuracy but in
much less time so I'm thrilled that eBay
who's been using these cloud debut pods
has been able to take advantage of this
benefit all ready for their visual
search models to achieve enormous speed
ups on much larger data sets than
imagenet and one of our colleagues from
ebay is here in the audience today so
the challenge is visual search which is
an enormous part of the ebay experience
customers all over the world are
listening more than 1 billion products
and needs to be able to find what they
want when they want it but even with the
training image set that's a subset of
that 55 million images training a model
with on-premise hardware was taking
months and it was impossible to iterate
and try out new things as quickly as the
computer vision team wanted to so to
scale further ebay switched to these
cloud TPU pods that are now available to
everybody in alpha with the goal of
delivering a new image classification
model optimized for TP use and then
finding the right hyper parameter
settings for their extremely large data
set I'm happy to report that the results
have been fantastic and the progress is
continuing so in some cases it's hard to
do an apples-to-apples comparison
between something that was trained for
months and months with something that's
trained in just a few days but in some
cases the speed up was almost a hundred
x over the hardware system that they've
been using previously and when you pick
the best model of the ones that were
tested the accuracy boost was 10% which
is enormous for a production model so
what this means is that eBay is now
closer to continuous machine learning
training multiple models each week to
keep product search results fresh
pulling in new advances from
cutting-edge research that's being
published in the open all the time we
think this is a really promising step
towards reinventing the way that eBay's
customers visually shop and experience
the site so let me say a little bit more
about performance since I know that
that's something that's interesting to
all of you who are pushing up against
the limits of whatever setup you
currently have now it's important to
measure performance carefully often
you'll see isolated statistics out of
context thrown around on the internet
there's many samples per second or this
many times faster or what-have-you
it's really ideal it's not always
possible but it's really ideal to focus
on real-world data on time to accuracy
and cost in an apples-to-apples
comparison across two different systems
and so when I say real-world data what I
mean here is that often you'll see
results that are achieved with synthetic
data which just means random numbers fed
through the device to see how fast they
can run it's like lifting a car off the
pavement and then flooring the
accelerator and measuring how fast the
wheels spin it's cool makes a loud noise
but what you really care about is the
whole system performance of a real data
set flowing into your system without any
bottlenecks and being processed to get
to the results that you want or serve
the models that matter to your customers
also you'll often hear people report
results without saying anything about
convergence to the expected accuracy but
ultimately that's what matters to you in
your business if you're doing a
pedestrian detector for autonomous
driving it really is important how
accurate that pedestrian detector model
is and even a loss of a percentage point
is something that you take very
seriously and want to avoid so finally
we're trying to move away from chip to
chip or system to system comparisons
because they're going to be increasingly
meaningless since there's this Cambrian
explosion of new hardware architectures
to deal with the end of Moore's law and
instead we're trying to look at the
total cost of one system versus another
in the public clouds that are accessible
to everybody
finally we're investing a lot of energy
and making ml benchmarks reproducible
via open source implementations so you
don't have to trust my word for it
can take anything that you're about to
see run it yourselves on cloud GPUs and
see if you measure the same results the
best and most carefully designed
contests we've seen so far has been
organized by some Sanford researchers
it's called Don bench and they really
focused on these metrics that I just
mentioned time to accuracy and total
cost especially on image net but also on
CFR 10 and question-answering data set
and so I'm happy to report that cloud
GPUs came in number one in Don bench for
image net training cost hitting their
accuracy in just 7.5 hours for under $50
but now the field is moving so fast this
was earlier this year already with the
new promotional pricing that comes down
to 34 dollars and with preemptable x'
that's just over $10 which is kind of
amazing so but wait there's more if we
look at the res net results here which
at that time we're achieving something
like three thousand two hundred fifty
images a second and hitting the accuracy
that you expect in just under nine hours
that costs just under $60 now that
sounds forty dollars running the exact
same code or almost under $13 at
preemptable prices the pod as I promised
scales up linearly so a half pod was
able to get the job done not in hours
but in 30 minutes and actually that
includes a lot of overhead that doesn't
really make a lot of sense at this scale
because you end up having to checkpoint
every few seconds as you're getting
through the Don Budge challenge because
you wouldn't do in real life so if you
eliminate the checkpoint overhead that's
just twenty three point nine minutes to
get to this level of accuracy that's
really what I mean about enabling teams
to iterate faster than they ever could
before good question talk to sales so
pricing is not announced for alpha but I
highly encourage you to talk to our
sales team to get a sense of what this
will cost furthermore I'd like to say
that at dawn bench there was a third
place entry that was very clever it was
from a team called fast AI
and they had an entry at $72 at the time
that had to clever tricks one was
progressively scaling up the image size
during training because you don't need
the high-resolution at the very
beginning it turns out and they also use
the more aggressive learning rate
schedule and so after the contest we
reproduce these algorithmic changes on
the cloud TPU and open sources of
changes and that takes resonant 50
training cost on cloud TPU from the new
40 83 down to 17 and that is affordable
even with predictable on-demand pricing
but with preemptable pricing the cost is
now down to just $5 so we're obviously
trying to drag this as close to zero as
we can because we know that you need to
train these models over and over again
to make progress and you want to train a
lot of them in parallel to do a gigantic
hyper parameter search or neural
architecture search on every new product
that you're going to release so to
experience this performance like I
mentioned before client GPUs are now GA
and widely available start with our
QuickStart or our tutorials use one of
our reference models and hopefully this
will be helpful to you so where do we go
from Dawn bench well there's a new
benchmark contest in town that's even
more comprehensive and challenging
that's organized across many different
institutions companies universities and
you can find more information at ml perf
and the LPers org I think this is going
to be really exciting with the results
for a version 0.5 of the benchmark late
in this October so how do you start
using these cloudy views or TP pods
today well I recommend that you start
with one of our reference models and I
want to emphasize that we have a wide
range of these reference models that are
great starting points even if you're
heavily invested in some model in-house
it's useful to step back and say well
wait what is the underlying task here
whether it's object detection or speech
recognition or language processing or
something else and see if we have a
reference model that corresponds to that
task because then just as a baseline you
can take your data connect it to our
reference model and here's a whole range
of our reference models and immediately
get a result in just a few days maybe
even an after
before you think about the more
intensive process of taking your
existing model and porting it over to a
new system and optimizing it so as you
can see here we've got image recognition
object detection machine translation
language modeling speech recognition and
even image generation some of this
cutting-edge stuff over on the right and
we're adding new models all the time so
I'll highlight a few of these and
provide some new performance numbers and
sort of us a mini case study on object
detection so you've heard a lot about
image classification I'd like to just
call out that our amoeba netd model that
one dawn bench is actually an
architecture that was discovered through
neural architecture search on the TPU so
it's a model that was designed from
scratch on the TPU made available open
source for all of you and it achieves
fantastic accuracy on the image net and
also on larger data sets object
detection is really interesting because
here you're processing larger images and
trying to localize many different
objects within them and so back at
Google i/o in May I showed this result
but I've updated the prices here for our
new promotional pricing your processing
896 by 896 images and at that time we
achieved 37 average precision on cocoa
which is pretty good in just six hours
and now that would cost you only $28 or
just nine dollars with preemptable but
with tentacle 1.9 we've made even
greater advances in efficiency and that
means if you're willing to let this run
just a little bit longer you can get to
thirty seven point seven AP on cocoa so
that's up from 37 that's pretty cool
it's not that much more expensive but
now this is just without any code
changes going from TPU v to the TPU v 3
because remember this is a family of
processors we want to make it as easy as
possible for you to scale up from
whether it's one device up to a pod or
from one generation to the next
so here Retina net with tensorflow 1.9
can achieve that same 37.7 average
precision on cocoa in just four point
one hours so it's 1.5 x faster with no
code changes and we've barely begun to
optimize for the new platform what's
even more interesting than that is what
happens when you have
additional memory available right
because the memory doubles from v2 to v3
so suddenly without a lot of engineering
effort you can process 1024 by 1024
images which I know is something that's
really interesting to a lot of
autonomous driving companies or medical
imaging companies that want to process
the largest images they can suddenly
you're up to 38.4 average precision
remember up from 37 originally in just
five point two hours and now that you're
able to iterate at this larger scale and
larger speed
you try out some data augmentation
techniques and that gets you to 41
average precision in just 10 hours
letting it run a little longer so this
is a great concrete example of the
general principle I introduced before
the faster hardware and that also larger
memory in this case gives you the
opportunity for more experimentation and
even higher accuracy for the models that
matter most to your business furthermore
I'm thrilled to announce that image
segmentation is coming soon so we've got
the deep black v3 model coming mask our
CNN which I know is a popular model out
there and more for those of you who
don't just want bounding boxes but you
want to know pixel by pixel where each
object is in an image I'll just
emphasize that TPS are not only about
computer vision here's a machine
translation with transformer achieving a
near state-of-the-art blue score on WMT
14 from english german 6.2 hours under
$30 under $10 for the preemptable it's
fantastic language modeling it's more
compute-intensive to train on the
language model 1 billion word data set
but this is the kind of thing that lets
you do things like smart reply or smart
compose that's helpful for messaging
apps and any kind of conversational
interaction where you want to save
people time predicting what's next and
this is an example of one of several
models that's in tensor to tensor
there's a link down here at the bottom
to is a numeral and it's all one word
and tensor to tensor is built on top of
tensor flow it's great for research
mixing and matching datasets model
architectures training processes and
you'll see a few others like this one
also there so speech recognition here
we've got a SR transformer giving you a
great word error rate in just 13 hours
7.9 word error rate and you can get down
to 7.3 if you're willing to let it train
a little longer
and again preemptable pricing
just under 20 bucks finally well almost
finally question answering this was the
winner of the Don Ben's question
answering contest and the team has
continued to make improvements such that
this now trades in just eight minutes
I've written estimated training cost
here because this is now so fast we may
have to rethink the other overheads to
see how to measure this cost accurately
it's too small to even register and that
question answering model now has an open
source implementation available which is
great so also at the cutting edge of
research image generation bits per
dimension is the key metric here and
lower is actually better so this two
point nine eight is close to the two
point nine to the state-of-the-art for
just one hundred thirty eight dollars or
forty four with preemptable pricing you
can generate these images from scratch
that look weirdly like the real-life but
not quite so I think this is a really
interesting research domain so please
consider starting with a reference model
even if you love the model that you've
already built even if you sunk an
enormous amount of Energon earing effort
into it it's really valuable to just lay
down a quick baseline with a public data
set or with one of your in-house data
sets using these reference models to
then guide your engineering choices
whether it's porting your existing model
maybe merging it with some a reference
code or starting with a reference model
fresh and then building from there so
these reference models are
high-performance they're open-source
they're cutting edge you know some of
the latest and greatest research like
amoeba net is immediately pushed into
these this pool of reference models that
are open source we're doing a lot of
continuous testing for performance and
accuracy to save you as much of that
trouble as we can because we know it's
complicated and expensive and these
reference models that you get up and
running quickly training on your own
data but I want to emphasize you're not
limited to reference models for example
here's another case study of
architecture search that a group at
Stanford did where they actually did
parallel runs using hundreds of cloud TP
use simultaneously each blue dot in this
image is a run training an image net
scale convolutional are ten on a TPU so
this is a lot of computation
here they were searching for a model
there's an archive link in the lower
right task-driven convolutional
recurrent models of the visual system is
the paper and they were looking for a
model that was a better fit for the
types of dynamics that you record if you
put electrodes in the brain and actually
listen to the primate visual cortex as
it's seeing and so here's a diagram of
the sort of space that they were
searching and it turns out that across
this this population of many different
models they found that these red
connections were selected for during the
search versus the others and then when
they went back and tried to fit these
models to some of the signals that they
were actually recording in primates they
found that these convolutional rnns were
a much better fit for the neural signals
in v4 in IT than typical just ordinary
convolutional feed-forward models that
you see typically in the literature
today so I think this is an interesting
new research direction and it's a group
that was able to do this from scratch on
their own using hundreds of cloud GPUs
so you can not only implement your own
models you can search for models
automatically using cloud GPUs so I
wanted to share a little bit more
information about the hardware just give
you a flavor of what makes these
accelerators different from other types
of processors that are available in the
market so the cloud keep you that I
mentioned before consists of this device
here which under those heat sinks has
four separate processors and all of this
64 gigabytes of high bandwidth memory
with a very high memory bandwidth among
the processors and it's connected to a
host server like you see here with PCI
v3 and so let's zoom in on just one of
these chips in the cloud TPU device well
that chip has a layout like this it's
got two cores and it's kind of scale
your unit it's got a vector unit and
most importantly it's got this matrix
unit which is this gigantic systolic
array that's an old idea and hardware
architecture but its newly relevant now
that so many of these cutting-edge
models use dense linear algebra it's
really the perfect fit for the systolic
array one interesting thing about this
is all the gray is that while it's
doing float32 accumulate like you're
used to it's actually using a different
filing point format behind the scenes
with no code changes for you necessary
although you can take further advantage
of be float16 if you want so it's using
be float16 and the multiplies and let me
tell you a little bit more about what
that means because I think this is one
of the unique advantages of the cloud
CPU so float32
I Triple E floating point has this
enormous range and those 32 bits are
divided as you see here with you know
the exponent and then the mantissa lots
of bits for the mantissa to track these
fine differences between numbers that's
important for high-performance computing
where you're tracking fine details in a
simulation but it turns out it doesn't
matter that much in machine learning
so some vendors have gone to I Triple E
float 16 which you can see here which
reduces both the exponent and the
mantissa and what that means is you end
up reducing the range and now if you're
programming with float 16 you have to
completely rewrite your model in a
different way on a model by model basis
it's very time consuming and subtle
because you have to keep all of your
activations and the rank ranges you
might have to do lost rescaling we're
trying in tensorflow to make this more
convenient but it's really hard and so
we actually use a different
floating-point format in the TPU that we
call B float 16 for the brain team which
is where we started this and there we
preserve the 8 bits of exponent and just
chop off the mantissa turns out this is
almost a drop-in replacement for float
32 across this huge range of machine
learning models that we see you only
have to be careful in a few small
situations maybe atom has a parameter
that you got to be careful to explicitly
cast the float 32 because there are so
many nines after the decimal point but
in general it's it's much easier to work
with b float 16 then with float 32 and
then that you know reduces your memory
usage and avoids memory bottlenecks it's
it's fantastic and if you want to see
how B float16 works a lot of our
reference models are already using it
transparently so you can see some
examples in you know the github
tensorflow TPU repository so just to
illustrate briefly how this matrix unit
actually does magic here's a 3x3 example
but imagine this is one
1:28 which is what we really have on the
device so what's happening as the data
streaming in is we're getting a lot of
great reuse of these intermediate
results within the systolic array in
this staggered fashion that's producing
the output that we want and so as long
as your problem has some dense linear
algebra core that can be mapped
efficiently to these systolic arrays
which we found is possible across this
wide range of applications that I called
out earlier this is going to be a great
fit for your machine learning both
training and also inference so stepping
back for just a second we've covered a
lot I just want to emphasize cloud cpv2
it's now GA it's widely available it's
in the u.s. it's in Asia it's in Europe
we've got regular pricing we've got
preemptable pricing it's an incredibly
affordable way to start with one of our
state-of-the-art reference models and
explore this frontier if you haven't yet
or if you're one of these folks part of
or leading a team of these cutting-edge
machine learning engineers and
researchers they'll thank you for having
access to orders of magnitude more
compute than you could possibly have
afforded before we've also gone through
how to measure performance carefully and
looked at some of these applications
across all these different domains not
just image recognition but also speech
language image generation and one other
thing I'd like to highlight here is that
cloud two views I've focused on using
cloud two views in Google compute engine
but that's just the lowest level of the
stack where we're giving you maximum
flexibility and control we're also
working to integrate cloud to be used
with all of the rest of Google cloud on
the storage side which I haven't written
here with GCS but also with BigTable and
with our betrayed G RPC services and
then here with cloud ml engine if you
want to use a higher level managed
service to keep track of all your
training jobs and kubernetes gke there's
a really interesting talk tomorrow on
mini go training and alphago zero like
model on hundreds of clouds of use using
gke it's going to be a fantastic talk so
check it out and I look for the
recording afterwards so we're really
introducing
a new platform for machine learning it's
it works well with tensorflow but also
with Karis and we're looking at other
frameworks as well and we hope it'll be
valuable to you as you're developing
cutting-edge new machine learning
enabled applications for your customers
all around the world so thanks very much
[Music]